you want to realize that the Givens are
clues or hints so what I would do is I
would mark on the diagram you know
visually so I can see that angle 2 is
congruent angle 3 I give it the same you
know marking so that I know that they're
congruent ok and then I want to prove
that angle 1 is congruent to angle 4 now
what I usually do is I try to work
through it on the diagram before I get
into the actual steps here in our two
column proof and I just try to reason it
out before I get into the steps so I
don't get lost as to where I'm going
with everything now when you do these
proof so you can work through them
forwards and sometimes it's helpful to
actually take what you're trying to
prove and work backwards okay if that
makes sense so I'll show you what I mean
so what I would first do is I'd
recognize that 1 and to see how they
form a straight line that means that
they add up to 180 degrees or they're
supplementary you see how angle 3 and
angle 4 form a straight line again that
means that they add up to 180 and
they're supplementary but what the
congruent suppliments theorem says is
that if you have two angles okay that
are supplementary to each other okay and
these two angles are supplementary and
these two angles are congruent to each
other then angle 1 and angle 4 must be
congruent to each other okay let me see
if I can do that in a slightly different
way like say for example you had 120
degree angle here and you had a 60
degree angle here and you had a hundred
and 20 angle degree angle over here well
there's two different versions of the
congruent supplements theorem this first
version is that these two angles add up
to 180 and these two angles add up to
180 but you see how we're using the 60
degree angle in both of those
supplementary situations these out of 20
of these out of 20 we're using 60
degrees in both cases and that tells us
that these two angles the 120 degree
angles are equal to each other now
normally they're not going to give you
the angle measures but I'm just showing
you just to illustrate here now say we
introduced a fourth angle here that's
also 60 degrees and so these two angles
are congruent to each other right that's
two sixty degree angles will just write
equal there so these add up to 180 these
add up to 180 but these two angles are
congruent to each other what do you know
about these two angles ah they must be
congruent as well so that's the
congruent supplements theorem I could
just do one more example and that's
kind of a funny example I usually tell
my students this like if I'm standing up
like this and somebody stands on my
shoulders and they barely touch the
ceiling right and then let's say you're
standing right next to me okay and
somebody stands on your shoulders and
they just barely touch the ceiling and
let's just say that these two people
that are on both of our shoulders are
the same height what would that say
about my height and your height well it
would mean that we're the same height
right what we're doing is we're using
these two people that are standing on
our shoulders and they're the same
height as one another we're using them
as measuring tools to compare our two
Heights now the ceiling in this analogy
is the 180 degrees if they're adding up
to the total height of the ceiling or in
this case they add up to 180 degrees and
that's allowing us to compare our
Heights and say that they're equal okay
so let's get into this proof basically
the first thing I would do step number
one is I would just list the Givens
usually I would like to write down the
Givens first just to get them out of the
way
so angle 2 is congruent to angle 3 and
that's that's done so now step number 2
I would state that angle 1 and angle 2
form a linear pair so I'm just going to
write form a linear pair okay and I'm
also going to do that for angle 3 and
angle 4 so angle 3 and angle 4 also form
a linear pair and the reason is is it's
the definition of a linear pair okay
it's they form a straight line you could
also say given from the diagram see
diagram so they form a straight line
okay now okay now step number 3 what we
have is we have angle 1 and angle 2 are
supplementary and then we also have
angle 3 and angle 4 are supplementary
and supplementary just means that you
know they add up to 180 degrees if
they're a linear pair you know they form
a straight angle and the reason for this
would just be the linear pair theorem ok
linear pair theorem linear just means
line pair means to write so the two
angles add up to a straight line or form
a straight line and they're
supplementary and then the last step is
what we were talking about earlier
which is the congruent supplements
theorem and whatever you're trying to
prove that's always gonna be the last
step in your proof so angle 1 is
congruent to angle 4 angle 1 is
congruent to angle 4 and again that's
the congruent congruent I'm just going
to abbreviate supplements theorem and
again just to recap if you have two
angles that are supplementary and these
two angles are supplementary but these
two angles are congruent then angle 1
and angle 4 are going to be congruent to
each other by that congruent supplements
theorem so I hope this helps you
understand how to work through kind of a
beginning geometry proof using the
congruent supplements theorem
subscribe to the channel check out some
of the other geometry proofs on Mario's
math tutor and YouTube channel and I
look forward to seeing the future videos
I'll talk to you soon